All right, let's get into audience questions
for the week. We do have these to a special
Senate runoff elections coming up on
January 5th. The question I'm getting
more and more is can we trust the polls? And
the answer is it doesn't actually matter.
And I'll explain why in a moment. So as a
reminder, we have two Senate races that will
determine who controls the Senate. They're both
in Georgia. They're both runoffs. The first one
is incumbent Kelly Lefler against challenger
Raphael Warnock. The second is incumbent David
Perdue against challenger John OSF. There are
no debates happening in the OSV Perdue debate
because Perdue said he won't he's not going to
do it. That's after OSF absolutely obliterated
him. In the last debate they had we did see a
debate between Lefler and Warnock. Lefler appeared
to have a software malfunction where she was just
repeating the same thing over and over again.
Radical liberal Raphael Warnock, radical liberal
for our work on and on and on. A really weird.
But in any case, the polling is very, very
close. If you look right now at the USCIRF
Perdue polling, it's USCIRF plus one on average.
If you look at the Warnock Lefler polling,
it's Warnaco plus a little bit over one. And of
course, both races have polls saying it's actually
the Republican who's winning. So the answer
to can we trust the Georgia Senate polls is it
doesn't matter. And what I mean by that is they're
basically 50 50. If you trust them, it's 50 50
and thus you have to vote because it's going to be
close. If you don't trust them, then we don't know
what the race is looking like, in which case you
would just go and have to vote. So it's actually
there's no, you know, Electoral College
consideration where well, if Biden's winning
nationally, but in my state he's not. And I vote.
But if in California, it wouldn't know it. None
of it matters. It's it's could not be simpler if
you believe the polls. This is tied and everybody
should vote. If you believe the polls can't be
trusted, then you should vote because the real
polling could be anything and we don't in both
scenarios. We should be getting out and voting.
Now, as a reminder, the importance of these three
elections should not be understated. These two
elections, rather, should not be understated.
With these two seats, Democrats would have a 50
50 tie in the Senate. And what this means is that
the possibility of Joe Biden getting big campaign
policy done goes way up because in the case of a
50 50 tie, Kamala Harris gets to cast the deciding
ballot as vice president of the United States. You
can't possibly overstate the importance of this.
I believe there is no chance of anything being
done on health care if Democrats don't take
these two seats. I don't believe you will see
big climate and energy green energy legislation
if Democrats don't take these two seats. I don't
I don't even know for sure whether you get tax
reform, even even negotiating with Republicans.
I don't know if you get tax reform done.
If you don't get these two seats. Now, on the
counter side, on the opposite side to this
is the reality that many of you have
brought up when I open up the phone lines,
which is even with a 50 50 split. Is Joe Manchin
from West Virginia, the most conservative
Democratic senator, going to vote for some of this
stuff Joe Biden wants? We don't know. It's very,
very much unclear. But it's also possible that
you could find a vote or two from the Republican
Party among Republicans whose constituents are
more moderate. I know it's almost like a meme at
this point, but Susan Collins in Maine, maybe Lisa
Murkowski in Alaska, there are some possibilities.
But the important thing is that without these
two seats, these aren't even conversations. So
phone bank, text bank donate if you can
doorknock safely. If you're in Georgia,
we should all be focused in on these races.
And we will we will continue to be. But
whether you trust the polls or not,
it doesn't matter. Everyone must vote